mathieu bonno prépare l'ouverture de son
restaurant il connaît bien le milieu de
la restauration et surtout les enjeux
reliés à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
peut vous donner le meilleur salaire
d'un employé si tu donnes pas des belles
conditions qui arrive justement au
travail puis des conditions de mer ben
sa large possible une situation que
constate déjà depuis plusieurs années
l'association des restaurateurs du
québec
c'est un vrai que généralisée qui est
partout alors il faut travailler à
l'identification de solutions qui sont
multiples c'est certain que d'offrir des
conditions de travail adéquates dans
contexte actuel c'est une nécessité
sans quoi on va perdre nos les bonnes
ressources dont on profite présentement
les restaurants peine à recruter des
employés surtout dans les cuisines
c'est difficile trouver des employés
qualifiés formés puis une fois qu'on les
a c'est encore plus difficile de garder
ses seuls défi c'est quand pourquoi
parce que la demande est tellement forte
le besoin est tellement fort que les
employés vont changer d'emploi pour 50
sous de l'heure de plus fait qu'il faut
trouver d'autres façons de les motiver
que de l'argent
leur solution offrir une assurance
collective à leurs employés qui couvre
les soins médicaux dentaires et si que
l'invalidité on l'offre à toutes nos
emplois temps plein qui ont donné des
services continus depuis un an couple
avec tout ce monde là on veut les garder
en vie qu'ils soient heureux ça donne un
objectif à ce qui vient d'arriver
les chaînes hôtelières et les grands
restaurants offrent pour la plupart des
assurances à leurs employés mais c'est
une initiative peu commune pour les
petits établissements pour de vrai ce
matin j'ai eu une entrevue avec une
jeune cuisinière actuelle est prête à
venir travailler ici
puis quand on est en cage et j'ai dit
cet argument leur en fait on croyait pas
c'est peu commun c'est pas commun du
tout moi en disant j'ai jamais vu un
endroit non syndiquée qui est pas
institutionnel qui offre des assurances
ça nous motive nous les gueux à vouloir
continuer de travailler puis à surpasser
pour justement avoir se passe est une
belle chance qu'on en avant les
assurances ya par exemple à ce qu'ils
ont reçu il n'y a pas de recette miracle
pour contrer la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
mais visiblement améliorer le bien-être
des employés est peut-être l'une des
solutions ici marie michel lauzon
radio-canada repentigny